well that's a super powerful idea
of generating the language almost like
uh rigorous a b testing for you
that works to find the the best customer
for your thing I mean to me
advertisement when done well
just finds a good match between a human
being and a thing that will make that
human being happy
yeah totally and do that if as
efficiently as possible when it's done
well people actually like it you know
it's um yeah I think there's a lot of
examples where it's not done well and
it's annoying and I think that's what
kind of gives it a bad rap but
um but yeah a lot of the stuff is
possible today I mean obviously a b
testing stuff is built into a lot of
these Frameworks the thing that's new is
having technology that can generate the
ideas for about what to a B test so
that's exciting so this will just be
across like
everything that we're doing with all the
metaverse stuff that we're doing right
it's like you want to create worlds in
the future you'll just describe them and
then it'll create the code for you so
it's a natural language becomes the the
interface we use for
all the ways we interact with the
computer with
with the digital or them yeah yeah
totally yeah which is what everyone can
do using natural language and with
translation you can do it any kind of
language
um I I mean for the personalization is
really really really interesting
yeah it unlocks so many possible things
I mean I for one look forward to
creating a copy of myself
I know we talked about this last time
but this has since the last time this
becomes now we're closer
much closer like I could literally just
haven't interacted with some of these
language models I could see the Absurd
situation where I'll have a uh large uh
or a Lex language model and I'll have to
have a conversation with him about like
Hey listen
like you're just getting out of line and
having a conversation where you
fine-tune that thing to be a little bit
more respectful or something like this I
mean that's that's going to be the
that seems like an amazing product
for businesses for humans just not not
just the assistant that's facing the
individual but the assistant that
represents the individual to the public
both both directions
there's basically a layer that is the AI
system through which you interact with
the outside world with the outside world
that has humans in it that's really
interesting and you that have social
networks that connect billions of people
it seems like a
heck of a large scale place to test some
of this stuff out
yeah I mean I think part of the reason
why creators will want to do this is
because they already have the
communities on our services
yeah and and a lot of the interface for
this stuff today
are chat type interfaces and and between
WhatsApp and and messenger I think that
those are you know just great great ways
to
interact with people so some of this is
philosophy but do you see do you see any
near-term future where you have some of
the people you're friends with
our AI systems on these social networks
on Facebook on Instagram even even on
WhatsApp having having conversations
where some heterogeneous some human some
is AI I think we'll get to that
um you know and you know if only just
empirically looking at
then Microsoft released this thing
called show ice several years ago in in
China when it was a pre-lm chatbot
technology that it was a lot simpler
um than what's possible today
and and I think it was like tens of
millions of people were using this and
and just you know really it became quite
attached and you know built
relationships with it and I think that
there's
um you know their services today like
replica where you know people are doing
things like that and
um so I think that there's there's
certainly
you know needs for companionship that
people have you know older people
um
uh and it's I I think most people I
don't have as many friends as they would
like to have right if you look at
um there's some interesting demographic
studies around
like the average person has
the number of close friends that they
have is
um fewer today than it was 15 years ago
and I mean
that gets to like this is like the core
thing that
that I think about in terms of you know
Building Services that help connect
people so I think you'll get tools that
help people connect with each other are
going to be you know the primary thing
that we want to do
um so you can imagine you know AI
assistance that you know just do a
better job of reminding you when it's
your friend's birthday and how you could
celebrate them right it's like right now
we have like the little box in the
corner of the website that tells you
whose birthday it is and stuff like that
but it's
um but you know at some level you don't
just want to like send everyone a note
that's the same note saying happy
birthday with an emoji right so having
something that's more of an you know a a
social assistant in that sense and like
that can you know update you on what's
going on in their life and like how how
you can reach out to them effectively
help you be a better friend I think
that's something that's super powerful
too
um but
yeah beyond that
um and there are all these different
flavors of
kind of personal AIS that I think could
exist so I think an assistant is sort of
the the kind of simplest one to wrap
your head around but
um
like a mentor or a life coach
um if someone who can give you advice
um who's maybe like a bit of a
cheerleader who can help pick you up
through all the challenges that that um
you know inevitably you know we all go
through on a daily basis and that
there's probably you know some some role
for something like that and then you
know all the way you can you might just
go through a lot of the the different
type of kind of functional
relationships that people have in in
their life and you know I would I would
bet that there will be companies out
there that take a crack at at um at a
lot of these things so
um I don't know I think it's part of the
interesting Innovation that's going to
exist is is that there there's certainly
a lot
um like education tutors right it's like
I just look at you know my kids
learning to code and you know they love
it
um but you know it's like they get stuck
on a question and they have to wait till
like I can help answer it right or
someone else who they know can help
answer the question in the future
they'll just there will be like a coding
assistant that they have that is like
designed to you know be perfect for
teaching a five and a seven-year-old how
to code and and they'll just be able to
ask questions all the time and you know
be extremely patient it's never going to
get annoyed at them right
um I think that like there are all these
different kind of relationships or
functional relationships that we have in
our lives that
um they're really interesting and I
think one of the big questions is like
okay is this all gonna just get bucketed
into
you know One Singular AI I just I just
don't I don't think so do you think
about let's actually a question from
Reddit uh what the long-term effects of
human communication when people can talk
with in quotes talk with others through
a chat bot that augments their language
automatically rather than developing
social skills by making mistakes and
learning uh will people just communicate
by grunts in a generation and do you
think about long-term effects at scale
the integration of AI in our social
interaction
yeah I mean I think it's mostly
good I I mean that that was that
question was sort of framed in a
negative way but I mean we were talking
before about
language models helping you communicate
with uh it was like language translation
helping you communicate with people who
don't speak your language I mean at some
level
would all this social technology is
doing is helping people
um
Express themselves
better to people
in in situations where they would
otherwise have a hard time doing that so
part of it might be okay because you
speak a language I don't know that's a
pretty basic one that you know I don't
think people are going to look at that
and say it's sad that do we have the
capacity to do that because I should
have just learned your language right I
mean that's that's pretty high bar but
um
but overall I'd say um
there are all these impediments
and language is an imperfect way
for people to express thoughts and ideas
it's you know one of the best that we
have we have that we have art we have
code
but language is also a mapping of the
way you think the way you see the world
the way who you are and one of the
applications I've recently talked to a
person who who's uh actually a jiu jitsu
instructor
um he said that when he uh emails
parents about
their son and daughter
um that they can improve their
discipline in class and so on he often
finds that he comes off a bit of more of
an than he would like so he uses
GPT to translate his original email into
a nicer email
we hear this all the time a lot of
creators on our services tell us that
one of the most stressful things
um is basically negotiating deals with
Brands and stuff like the business side
of it because they're like I mean they
do their thing right and and you know
the creators they're they're excellent
at what they do and they just want to
connect with their Community but then
they get really stressed you know they
go into their their DMS and they see
some brand wants to do something with
them and they
don't quite know how to negotiate or how
to push back respectfully and
um so I think building a tool that can
actually allow them to do that well is
you know one simple thing that that I
think is just like an interesting thing
that that we've heard from a bunch of
people that that they'd be interested in
but I'm going back to the broader idea
um
I I don't know I mean you know I just
Priscilla and I just had our third
daughter
um congratulations thank you
and and you know it's like one of the
saddest things in the world is like
seeing your baby cry right but like it's
like what why is that right it's like
well because babies don't generally have
much capacity to tell you what they
care about otherwise right it's not
actually just babies right it's um you
know my five-year-old daughter cries too
because she sometimes has a hard time
expressing you know what what um matters
to to her and and I was thinking about
that and it's like well you know
actually a lot of adults get very
frustrated too because they can't they
have a hard time expressing things in a
way that going back to some of the early
themes that maybe is something that you
know is a mistake or maybe they have
pride or something like all these things
get in the way so I don't know I think
that all these different technologies
that can help us navigate the social
complexity and actually be able to
better express our what we're feeling
and thinking
I think that's generally all good and um
there are all these these concerns like
okay are people gonna have worse
memories because you have Google to look
things up and and I think in general a
generation later you don't look back and
lament that I think it's just like wow
we have so much more capacity to to do
so much more now and I think that
that'll be the case here too you can
allocate those cognitive capabilities to
like deeper like nuanced thought yeah
uh yeah but it's change so with with uh
just like with Google search
the the additional language models large
language models
you basically don't have to remember
nearly as much
just like with stack Overflow for
programming now that these language
models can generate code right there I
mean I find that I write like maybe
eighty percent ninety percent of the
code I write is is uh not generated
first and then edited I mean so you
don't have to remember how to write
specifics of different functions okay
that's great and it's also it's not just
the the specific
coding I mean in the in the context of
uh of a large company like this I think
before an engineer can sit down to code
they first need to figure out all of the
libraries and dependencies that you know
tens of thousands of people have written
before them and
um you know one of the things that I'm
excited about they're working on is it's
not just um you know tools that help
Engineers code it's tools that can help
summarize the whole knowledge base and
and help people be able to navigate all
the internal information and I think
that's
um in the experiments that I've done
with this stuff I mean that's
on the public stuff you just you know
ask ask
um
one of these models to build you a
script that does anything and it
basically already understands what the
best libraries are to do that thing and
pulls them in automatically it's I mean
I think that's super powerful that was
always I the most annoying part of
coding was that you had to spend all
this time actually figuring out what the
resources were that you were supposed to
import before you could actually start
building the thing yeah I mean there's
of course
the flip side of that I think for the
most part is positive but the flip side
is if you Outsource that thinking to an
AI model you might miss nuanced mistakes
and bugs they're good you lose the skill
to find those bugs
and those bugs might be uh the code
looks very convincingly right
but it's actually wrong in a very subtle
way
but that's that's the trade-off that we
uh
that we face as human civilization when
we build more and more powerful tools
when we stand on the shoulders of taller
and taller Giants we could do more but
then we forget how to do all the stuff
that they did
foreign
it's a weird trade-off yeah I agree I
mean I think it's I think it is very
valuable in your life to be able to do
basic things too